Speaker 1: We have to start today with something
so important and of such consequence, but
which regularly generates almost no interest
from our audience, which is foreign policy
and what's going on right now with Russia
and Ukraine, as we've been covering and as
many of you have been seeing on a variety
of different media outlets.
Russia has been massing troops at the border
with Ukraine.
Now, even that statement is questioned by
some who want to defend Putin or claim that
that's all a lie for the purposes of furthering
American imperialism or whatever.
We're going to have a real hard time having
any conversation if we can't even agree on
the fundamentals, but that's going on.
And now the discussion is among the United
States, as well as other Naito allies about
if, when and how to mobilize military resources
to NATO's allies surrounding Ukraine.
Remembering that Ukraine is not part of NATO's.
And that's a piece of this as well, with the
question of what would happen with those troops
if indeed Russia did push into Ukraine and
what would be Russia's reason for doing so.
When does Vladimir Putin really plan to do
that, or is he only making it appear as though
he might plan to do that?
So the latest news is that the Pentagon has
put 8500 troops on what they are calling heightened
alert, and that Joe Biden was presented with
a number of options, including moving troops
and equipment from other parts of Europe into
Poland, Romania and other neighboring countries
to Ukraine.
Again, remembering that Ukraine itself is
not a NATO's ally, the U.S. is discussing
the deployment of military forces to Eastern
Europe with Naito allies.
Lloyd Austin has played it placed 8500 troops
on heightened alert to assist with the defense
of Naito allies.
We have a clip of that.
Here is John Kirby, the spokesperson from
the Pentagon.
Speaker 2: I want to provide some facts on
these preparations that will reinforce our
commitment to NADO and to the NATO's response
force and increase our readiness.
Secretary Austin has placed a range of units
in the United States on a heightened preparedness
to deploy, which increases our readiness to
provide forces if NATO's should activate the
NEF or if other situations develop.
All told, the number of forces that the secretary
has placed on heightened alert comes up to
about 8500 personnel,
Speaker 1: so we don't know what's going to
happen yet.
There are all sorts of different speculations,
which quite frankly, aren't super interesting
to me because we just don't know what Vladimir
Putin is thinking.
But one of the most interesting aspects of
this is how different political factions in
the U.S. have responded.
As many of you now probably know on the Trump
right, there is indeed a pro-Putin pro-Russia
wing which developed under Trump.
And it came in part from Trump's sort of deference
to Vladimir Putin for lack of a better term.
Not saying Putin is a puppet master of Trump
in any direct way.
I'm not saying they colluded together to figure
you don't have to believe any of that stuff.
That's not what I'm saying.
Trump has been enamored with strongman, authoritarian
dictator types.
He talked about how he and Kim Jong UN fell
in love.
I might even have that clip.
We fell in love,
Speaker 2: and then we fell in love.
Exactly.
Speaker 1: You guys know all this stuff.
And to that end, we have seen a lot of these
Trumpists kind of become enamored similarly
with Putin and Russia.
Similarly, there are some on the left what
I tend to call.
Here we go.
The revolutionary left, the Stalinist Leninist
left, and that's lenahan.
By the way, some of you write to me and spell
Lenin like John Lennon.
And I'm wondering, like, who do these?
Who do they think I'm referring to when I
say Leninist anyway?
There are some there as well who have become
very deferential to Russia.
Usually they are sort of pro Chavez Maduro
types.
Often they like Fidel Castro.
Sometimes their views on Syria are sort of
strange.
So there's that group as well.
But one of the really interesting things is
that there's kind of a factual firewall that
seems to be plaguing some where yesterday
I saw, for example, why is it that Tucker
saying we should be loyal to Russia is not
OK?
But Democrats saying we should be loyal to
Ukraine is OK.
Like, either way, you're just kind of picking
a side.
And of course, I'm not picking any sides.
I'm against aggression and I'm against strongman
authoritarians in this particular.
Case, it's Putin massing the troops at the
border with Ukraine, it is not Ukraine massing
troops at the border with Russia and throwing
signals as if they might invade Russia.
So you can have any analysis that makes sense
to you.
You can have a particular predilection for
Russia or Ukraine.
And quite frankly, I don't.
But to say it's sort of the same when one
side clearly is the one at least feigning
aggression, if not actually planning to carry
it out is not a very sensible analysis.
So now there's going to be some wait and see.
And if anybody is going to write in and say,
David, you imperialist bastard wanting us,
I don't want any aggression.
I don't want any invasion.
I don't want any war.
I don't want troop deployment.
I don't.
I don't want any of it.
I think it's all bad and and I'm selfishly
of that opinion.
I want stable economies.
What's happening in the stock market almost
daily is not pleasing to me, and I think it
would only get worse if these escalations
were so.
I'm against all of it.
I don't want the U.S. invading anybody or
anything like that.
Now, once you understand the dynamics of Ukraine
not even being in NATO and the discussion
with Biden and NATO's allies is about the
defense of NATO's allies in the area.
You understand that that conversation isn't
even the appropriate one to be having, but
that's what's going on.
We may know more within a day.
We may know more within weeks could be months.
We just don't know.